buenos días y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 para esta
entrevista consigne y pozuelo
indigenista etnógrafo explorador
activista y ex director de la fundación
nacional del indio buenos días y muchas
gracias por concedernos esta entrevista
señor pozuelo usted es considerado una
de las máximas autoridades de brasil en
relación a los pueblos indígenas
aislados y tiene un gran conocimiento
del valle de javarí porque fue usted
quien de marcó estas tierras indígenas y
lidera una expedición hace 20 años qué
implicaciones tiene el asesinato del
periodista británico don phillips y del
indigenista bruno pereyra para esta
región y para brasil 1 pereira o
indigenista
es una pérdida que va más allá de las
fronteras del valle de javarí
porque es una perdida nacional para los
pueblos indígenas en general
demuestra que todas las personas
involucradas en la protección del medio
ambiente de las tierras indígenas de los
pueblos aislados o no están sujetos a
esta violencia que hoy se impone de
norte a sur
y de este a oeste dentro de las
comunidades en las comunidades indígenas
el señor precisamente hace precisamente
20 años usted lideró una expedición de
110 días en el valle de javarí junto a
un equipo de 35 personas la mayoría
indígenas
me gustaría que contase lo que hizo allí
y cómo ha cambiado esta región desde
entonces
la motivación de la expedición fue que
yo constate que había cada vez más
personas que bajaban desde las cabeceras
de los ríos cruzando el valle de javarí
y algunos grupos que venían en canoas o
en balsas improvisadas
y la región por donde entraban es una
región donde viven varios grupos
indígenas
principalmente un grupo que es uno de
los más grandes allí
se llaman flecheros me preguntaba si
estas personas se habían encontrado con
los fleteros
o una pelea tal vez muertes están bien
los indios o no y esto sólo se puede
comprobar a través de una expedición
así que salimos y remontamos los ríos
hicimos un largo tramo en barcos grandes
otro largo tramo a remo
un largo tramo a pie en total 3.200
kilómetros sumando todo dentro del valle
de javarí y averiguamos que la aldea
estaba intacta
pero hay otras invasiones que son más
rápidas
los invasores entran y salen en busca de
madera de casa sobre todo para cazar y
pescar que es lo más rápido
y precisamente una ironía de la suerte
el asesino confeso de bruno y don
amarildo dacosta estuvo con usted en
aquella expedición usted lo descubrió
hace poco tiempo
había tres reporteros con nosotros entre
ellos scott wallace que escribió un
libro
fue el que me llamó y me dijo sidney ese
tipo estaba en la expedición y respondió
de verdad porque no me acordaba
después revise las cintas del vídeo que
grabé durante la expedición y descubrí
que estaba allí con nosotros
de repente te das cuenta de que una
persona puede tener una visión del mundo
un comportamiento
pero el tiempo puede hacerle cambiar de
tal manera que se convierte en el
enemigo contra el que luchas
fue su caso en este episodio que acabó
en muertes
creo que lo que cambió fundamentalmente
fue la intensidad de las cosas
a mi modo de ver entre las acciones
ilegales contra los indios
las peores son la tala de madera la caza
y la pesca esas eran las actividades
tradicionales en aquella época
no había por ejemplo el tema de la
minería todavía no había llegado esto ha
renacido recientemente
goleando todos si miramos a la amazonia
en general cree que la situación ha
empeorado en la época del presidente
yair bolsonaro
sin duda yo diría sin temor a
equivocarme con toda la historia del
indigenismo nunca los pueblos indígenas
han estado tan amenazados como hoy
por qué
porque esta mentalidad en contra de los
indígenas se consolidó en la cabeza del
gobierno
y
entonces fue una acción política pensada
organizada y está la actividad dentro
del gobierno
el resultado de todo eso es la muerte de
bruno la muerte de dos
tiroteos contra los indígenas cuando las
lanchas pasan en frente de las
comunidades esto es cada vez más común
es por eso que es por esta razón que
usted en marzo devolvió la medalla al
mérito indigenista que recibió hace 35
años
así es
y
de repente cogieron la medalla al mérito
indigenista y
entregaron esta medalla al verdugo que
oprime a los indios
yo creo que eso fue un enorme insulto
para los pueblos indígenas
en segundo lugar en aquellos que la
habían recibido algunos recibieron esta
medalla
metal y
yo me sentí primeramente solidario con
los iones en el segundo lugar me sentí
medio-largo y la medalla perdió su
función
varios grupos y varios grupos indígenas
han denunciado a bolsonaro ante la corte
penal internacional por genocidio y
ecocidio es decir por atentar contra el
ecosistema amazónico cree que esas
denuncias tendrán alguna consecuencia y
es poco probable
está muy bien que existan estas
denuncias porque por lo menos se da a
conocer la situación dentro del país
trabado que son organismos
internacionales
no tienen el poder para condenar a
ningún brasileño
ni el presidente de la república ni a
ningún político entonces es muy
interesante
es importante hacer esto en todos los
foros internacionales
pero siempre pensando
que lo que va a resultar de todo eso es
la divulgación la comprensión
y un conocimiento universal del problema
pero no habrá ningún castigo dentro de
brasil
o presidente bolsonaro face multas el
presidente bolsonaro ha hecho muchas
declaraciones en contra de los indígenas
ha dicho una y otra vez que los
indígenas tienen demasiadas tierras y
que cito literalmente mantener a los
indios en reservas de marcadas es
tratarlos como animales en un zoológico
estas son las palabras del presidente
usted siempre defendió la importancia de
respetar a los pueblos que permanecen
aislados sigue pensando lo mismo hoy en
día o el mundo ha cambiado y es
necesario revisar estos principios y sus
principios
mire con respecto a los pueblos aislados
sigo pensando lo mismo
[Música]
y
tuve la oportunidad de hacer contacto
con siete grupos indígenas diferentes
entonces tuve una experiencia muy buena
es difícil que usted encuentre a otros
que hayan tenido tantas oportunidades
como yo
entonces yo empecé a darme cuenta de
cuánto daño le estábamos haciendo a los
pueblos indígenas
y comencé a trabajar para cambiar la
política
estos pueblos nunca han sido integrados
y son discriminados y han sufrido
múltiples pérdidas
ahora con respecto a los que ya están en
contacto ellos merecen todo el apoyo que
cualquier brasileño tiene en materia de
educación sanidad
tienen que participar en la política
nacional para tener representantes entre
nosotros
esto es importante para ellos esta
conexión entre ellos y nosotros debe ser
más intensa para que puedan gestionar su
futuro
y usted citó algunas frases del
presidente me gustaría citar una que
para mí es casi un acto de guerra
de
personarnos le voy a decir que la
caballería estadounidense hizo un
excelente trabajo porque mató a todos
los indios
acaba la cambio la caballería de brasil
no hizo un buen trabajo porque dejó
estos remanentes
esto es casi un acto de guerra una
declaración de guerra contra los pueblos
indígenas
no sé cómo clasificar esto es indecente
o genocida
cuál ha sido su experiencia más
memorable ya sé que tuvo muchas tuvo
contacto con muchos indígenas no
contactados
con trata de una experiencia
y cada contacto es una experiencia única
de vida
pero por ejemplo el trabajo que se hizo
con el grupo indígena de los arar a que
eran tres grupos diferentes
y fue el trabajo más notable
porque fue a través de él que yo llegué
a la conclusión de que debería trabajar
por una reforma nacional y no hacer más
contacto con ellos
porque yo logré organizar un frente
donde tenía todo para evitar algún tipo
de tragedia cuando organicé la
expedición pensé no permitiré la muerte
de un solo indio logra muertes y dos o
tres murieron cayeron enfermos fue gripe
yo tenía médicos
tenía un helicóptero tenía medicamentos
medicamentos
pero ellos cuando caían enfermos
se llevará el bosque en busca de sus
medicinas naturales
tuvimos que buscar los recogerlos en
camilla
y llevarlos en brazos tuvimos que
rescatar los de la selva para que no
hubiese más muertes
pero fue una terrible decepción porque
se suponía que nadie debía morir
desde colonizado desde la colonización
brasil ha perdido el 70% de su población
indígena como ve el futuro de los más de
300 pueblos indígenas que viven hoy en
brasil viendo cómo está la amazonía
yo creo que el futuro de los pueblos
indígenas depende más de nosotros que de
los propios indios
porque el estado tiene la potestad de de
marcar la tierra y el estado tiene la
potestad de cuidar de su salud
y que ha hecho el estado por ellos si
seremos capaces de tener una mirada
descender y correcta como hermanos que
somos todos
creo que a pesar de nuestra maldad
ellos sobrevivirán pero a través de
grandes luchas con mucho trabajo con
grandes pérdidas
con angustia con dolor todo eso podría
ser evitado si tuviéramos una mirada
fraternal
muy pobre cada señor por suelo para esa
entrevista y muchas gracias a ustedes
por acompañarnos hasta aquí pueden
seguir la programación en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom